c'est une rumeur fascinante qui dit qu
hitler théoriquement mort le 30 avril
1945 dans son bunker à berlin avec sa
femme eva braun s'est en fait enfui
enfui peut-être en amérique latine et
probablement même au brésil
cette histoire d'où elle vient elle
vient en fait du fait d'abord qu'on n'a
pas retrouvé le corps d'hitler
quand les soviétiques arrive dans le
même coeur au début du mois de mai 1945
ils ne découvrent que des corps calcinés
parce que hitler et ewa brandt selon la
version officielle se sont suicidés et
hitler a demandé qu'on brûle le corps
craignant que leurs corps ne soient
ensuite utilisé humilié frappé exposés
comme celui de mussolini
quelque temps avant à milan à la
vindicte populaire
donc les soviétiques arrive et ne
découvre rien mais si la rumeur c'est
enkystée et s'est développée en fait ça
tient largement à un homme et cet homme
c'est staline parce qu'en réalité très
tôt au mois de mai staline a la
certitude que ce corps c'est bien celui
d'hitler il le sait parce qu'il a fait
venir
l'assistante du dentiste d'hitler qui a
pu analyser la dentition du corps
puisque les dents résiste résiste au feu
et résiste à l'embrasement du corps et
elle est persuadée elle dit c'est hitler
donc staline est au courant mais
lorsqu'il reçoit une délégation
américaine d'aller aux occidentaux
il fait courir la rumeur qu'on en sait
rien que c'est pas hitler peut-être
qu'il ya même des bruits selon lesquels
hitler se serait enfuie via hambourg les
sous-marins l'amérique latine
probablement et cette rumeur entretenue
savamment par staline par l'absence du
corps par l'absence de reste par aussi
par la sidération parce que pour
beaucoup
hitler ne peut pas mourir il a survécu à
une tentative d'assassinât
ça fait des années qu'il est le monstre
absolu qu'on a entendu parler lui tous
les jours dans l'actualité
sa disparition elle est quasiment
inenvisageable alors cette rumeur
aujourd'hui à la pub elle a plus lieu
d'être et ça fait pas très longtemps il
ya un médecin légiste philippe charlier
qui s'est fait une spéciale
et et d'analysé des restes de corps
humains et d'essayer de comprendre les
raisons de des morts des corps qu'il va
essayer d'analyser dans son laboratoire
en france il a eu la chance de pouvoir
avoir accès au reste dites-leur en
russie donc il a eu la chance de pouvoir
regarder la mâchoire la dentition
d'hitler et même le et même le crâne il
est persuadé que ses dents sont les
dents d'hitler comment il le sait bien
il le sait parce qu'il ya une usure
spécifique parce qu'il y avait des bêta
2 de de soins dentaires très spécifiques
qui ont très bien été documentés par le
dentiste d'hitler il a pu voir que
c'était c'est dans la il sait que ce ne
sont pas des fausses dents mais des
vraies dents il s'est même qu' il y à
une patine mesures spécifiques des dents
d'hitler il voit aussi qu'il y à qui et
que ses dents traduisent un régime
végétarien hitler était végétarien il ya
pas mal de choses il voit même qu'il y a
des restes de remonter d'un anti acide
parce qu hitler avait d'acidité
peut-être lié au stress et l'angoissé et
qu'il prenait des médicaments et il y a
des traces de ces médicaments dans sa
dentition
donc ya pas de doute il a aussi appris
une chose intéressante c'est comment
hitler est mort essaye le voir en
regardant la boîte crânienne d'hitler on
a longtemps pensé qu hitler c'est à dire
une balle dans la bouche et lui dit pas
du tout il y a un trou dans la tête
il s'est donc très certainement selon
philippe charlier tirer une balle dans
la tête
voilà comment aujourd'hui près de plus
de soixante dix ans après on apprend
encore des choses sur les modalités de
la mort d'hitler est en tout cas une
chose est sûre c'est que la fuite
d'hitler savamment entretenu par staline
dès le mois de mai 1945 est bel et bien
une rumeur